hi there today I want to talk to you
about something that's very near and
dear to my heart and that is the flat
land environment now the flat land
environment is a terrain simulator that
has been developed by the Swiss train
company and I write the trains every day
so when I heard that there's a new rips
challenge to use the flat land
environment to make the train system in
my country better I of course was very
excited to do that so out of purely
egotistical reasons I'm going to present
you the flat land environment and I
invite you to join me in solving this as
a group together so the plan is
basically that we as a community sort of
do this challenge and completely in the
open with absolutely no aspirations of
winning or doing well or getting any of
the prizes just for the fun of it and
we'll see how far we'll come together
ok so let me demonstrate the environment
itself so as you can see here this is a
visualization of the environments there
are these agents in the environments and
they have to reach certain goals and of
course they can't crash if you look here
to the left there's a bunch of them
crashing right now which is not good and
your task is this is a multi agent
reinforcement learning problem all of
these agents have to reach their goal
and as fast as possible without any
collisions along these tracks right here
so you have based basically have to
specify for every single agent what
their next action at each time step yes
now the simulator is completely given to
you this is you can you can use it and
basically it's a planning problem for
multiple agents so you at each step you
have to decide does the agent move up
down left or right depending on whether
they can do so depending on the tracks
and whether something is in their way or
is not in their way and you know every
agent should reach their goal at the
closest possible or at the shortest
possible time
of course now there is this Europe's
2020 flat land challenge and basically
you can submit your solutions to their
eval
and there's a leaderboard and everything
and I thought it would be fun to
participate in this now I don't exactly
know what the what's the exact
connection to Europe's and so on but I
don't care honestly and this hasn't
started yet the timeline isn't really
open yet but it will start soon
but I think we can already start working
on it so the plan here is basically to
just you know kind of I have no idea of
traffic scheduling no idea absolutely
clueless but I know a lot about
reinforcement learning and even though
they say the challenge has already
existed last year in a very in a
slightly different form I think it was
just one agent instead of multi agent
and they said usually you have to
combine the reinforcement learning with
like some traditional stuff in order to
perform really well like screw that no
if I'm totally up for that but it would
be fun to just blast it off with RL and
go there so here's my proposition I have
opened a discord server for you to join
where you can join in and basically
people can discuss solutions to this
problem make a git github repository in
public and where people can submit pull
requests to and I'll be sort of the
merger and whatnot of of these and we
together sort of develop solutions now
my idea is that people would sort of
independently try things and then kind
of suggest things and if their work we
can merge them and whatnot and there's
just a lot of discussion in the discord
server I myself will not be like super
active on the server it's meant for the
community basically together to discuss
things and whoever wants to do that so I
just want to make some things clear from
the beginning I will be the dictator of
this project the 100% authoritarian no
compromises dictator if anything is
supposed to make be decided I may
Alecto hold a vote and I may not if we
win something I'll decide what to do
with it so just this because otherwise
there's just trouble right are we going
to win probably not because anyone who's
just come to our github rep or clone it
and then tune it a little bit more right
so I have no aspirations of winning
right here also as I already said I'm
not going to be super active in this
discord it's meant as as a method for
the community among itself to to
communicate third if you decide to put
in work don't expect others to do so
expect nothing if the project doesn't
work out we scrap it if people get tired
of it we scrap it if there's some other
problem we scrap it no expectations
never get mad at anyone else for not
doing as much work or anything like this
this is purely you participate because
you yourself want to learn something I
want to have fun and if someone else
does the same thing that's all the
better okay I will have a mainly
supervisory role in this in that I will
look at things that are happening and
advice and occasionally I of course will
participate myself so I hope the framing
of this is clear this is not me throwing
a hundred percent at this I just thought
it would be cool to do something as a
community together and this challenge it
seems like you know there are other
challenges like mine RL where everyone
needs to get a billion GPUs to even get
competitive this seems like small enough
that we could actually make a difference
here and hopefully do something very
cool alright if you still want to
participate even though I really really
really try to talk you this right now I
will leave a link to the discord
somewhere in the description and link to
the git repo as well and I hope that
some of you will be motivated enough to
come join and have some fun all right
I'll see you there bye bye
you
[Music]